hello everyone this is jacob yang from
cyanobiological
so today i would like to talk about
some strategies from our companies for
making codex19 reagents
to support cov2 research
diagnosis and vaccine development
and for this talk we mainly focus on the
antibody
development we will share the
information
about the decisions and the challenges
we made during the development processes
so this talk will divide it into five
major parts
first we'll just briefly go to the star
story 2
and what is this virus is
and what is the key factors about these
viruses
then we will talk about the strategies
for making
stars hope to antibiotic
development and then we will go through
some
results and the challenges we have made
and during the actual development for
the last two parts of the talk
we will just share some other related
tools
for the source cov2 research
and another pro vir our
viral coaching function
as we all know who
has characterized the cholinerging as
a pandemic and this
viruses has caused a lot of
public health threatening and also
affect our economic development
a lot so to
study covenanting there's a lot of
urgent need
for the research tools to help their
research
and diagnosis and therapeutics
this slide is just showing the complete
genome of the sarcov2
this virus has four major structure
proteins
n e s and n
fourteen non-structured proteins and
other several accessory
proteins so our work
is mainly focusing on spike
and the end proteins just as other
people did
this is just a diagram showing that
what these wires look like so we can see
that the ice pure gas protein
is on the surface of the wires and this
is a very key proteins for
the liver and shrink it help to interact
with the ac2 protein
and the human cells and help the fibers
infecting the
immune cells therefore spike is
the primary target for therapeutic
antibodies and
diagnosis and for the recent developing
vaccines
most of them are targeting proteins
and for this protein i want to add few
more informations
the spike protein can be divided into
s1 and s2 there's also a very important
domain on the s1 which is the rbdg name
this is the key domain for interacting
with the acet protein the other
key molecules we will talk about a lot
in the following sites is the energy
these proteins is a very sensitive
marker
when people study stars for original
sars
viruses
so when we compare the sequence of
alignment
for seven known human coronal viruses
we found that for the s proteins
the sauce cov2 and the sars
has a very high identity which is
similar
for the n protein so based on this
information
we did the following strategies for
making the reagents of for both
antigen and antibodies of parsleyov2
because there's a very high homology
sequence
alignment between source and cell cov2
we try to do the first strategies
and by asking the original source
antibodies
and the source antibody libraries to see
if you can find some antibodies and
recognize the source cov2
because the development speech is very
important at this time if we can obtain
the good antibodies or
other reagents for supporting the soft
theory to scientific research
it will help a lot for the following
vaccine development
and therapeutic development and the
third
strategy is start from the beginning we
will immunize the stars
cov-2 antigen and into
the antibody development
but the first key reagent
we need to have is the antigen the
antigen
from stars zeroe2 we will use
recombinant technologies for developing
the retirement
star civilian two antigens here are the
four
major expression holes available
now for recovering protein expression
and while we go through the
information we have about the science
ceo we choose
5 protein and n protein we know that
the spike protein is highly glycosylated
so here is just a diagram from one
reference
showing that there are couple
molecules can be modified
on the rbd region we also see that
in our results probably using htk
to 93 cells and the insect cells
for expressing a part of the spike
protein
we see the molecular weight differences
in these two
systems because of the glycosalation
pattern differences
therefore we chose the eukaryotic
expression host htk 293 cells
and the insect cells for expressing the
following
s and n proteins so here
are several proteins we obtain
for after the recombinant expression
and we do we produce the rbd
and sccb as one and several
spike fragments we also successfully
obtained the any proteins
once we check their hplc protections
we can see a high percentage
of the one speed component for
the proteins
then we are coming to our strategy
number one
and the number two we screen the sauce
antibodies for the sauce antibody
libraries
for us cov-2
antibodies this is one of the antibodies
we obtained
from the type antibodies
so this is the rapid monoclone
antibodies
when we check this antibody the
interaction between
the antibody and the source still we
dash to spec
proteins we can see their interaction
very well and then we also request
these antibodies to see it can
whether it can recognize the pseudo
viruses
of the cov-2 while the pseudo virus is
in fact the ac2
expression hdk293 cells we can clearly
see the interaction between the antibody
and pseudoviruses the bottom part of the
em picture is from one of the references
which is citing our
products and this monoclonal
antibody products you can see we got
very good
em results showing that we have
successfully
obtained one spike and body which can
recognize the sauce still with dash to
spike
we got pretty much the same results for
the earned proteins
we re-screened the stars and an antibody
and antibiotic libraries and obtain one
rapid monopoly
antibodies and these antibodies can
recognize the
sarcoid ii and protein
and also can work for the western blot
applications
our customers use these antibodies for
ihc analysis we got very few
pictures to detect the np
antigen in the kidney tissues
then we want to check the affinity of
these
new antibodies and we found that both
antibodies show very high
affinity interaction with their
proteins by octet
so for the strategy number three we want
to start from the beginning
we immunize the animals with the soft
seal with
two antigens including the spike and the
end
proteins since we want to
obtain the antibodies which can
hopefully they can recognize the natural
viruses
or they can have the neutralization
functions so we chose recombinant
proteins as the immunity
we immunize the immunogen in both mice
and
rapists to do the antibody development
fourth developing platform has been used
for the new antibody generation the
regular polyclonal antibodies
platform for classical hybridoma
we also use phage display library and b
cell antibody toning techniques for
monochromal antibody generation
then lastly we will test the application
validation by eliza
rhc virtualization we also want to test
if this antibody is specific for such
skill
2 or it can have fast productivity
to us to other formal viruses
so this is just one of the results we
obtained for
these new antibodies there are six
antibodies showing that we are testing
the
interaction by elasta with
sars spike proteins or
coe-spec proteins at two different
concentrations of the antigen
and we see that for the
antibody number one two three these
three antibodies
can interact with starch cov-2 spike
but do not interact with stars
the original source by proteins
which means this is probably the spice
specific
values we didn't show the result here
but we do
test these three antibodies
to see if they can recognize other
five human rhinoviruses and we found
that
mostly bodies are specific only
to the here we actually
so we successfully got a very high
specific acid
but whole specific antibodies which only
recognizing the new self-driving
viruses then we do the neutralization
essays and we found two antibodies which
can
neutralize the interaction between the
pseudoviruses and the ac2 expression
cells
so currently we have a good quality
plus cov2 antigens and we also obtain
several specific fast cov antibodies
so we did a lot of combination and
summarize several kits
for different areas of the applications
the last chart showing that this is
so this kit is used for swinging the
antibodies into eaters which is
for selecting their neutralization
antibodies
we also have the antigen detection
electricity by two by one pair of
antibodies
and then we can quantitate the amount of
antigen in your sample
we also have the antibody title and acid
kit
which help to detect your immunization
either of the antibody you
you obtain in the samples
meanwhile we are still working on
selecting more
sustainable reduction antibodies not
just for the specific antibodies we are
also willing to
obtain some antibodies which can
recognize the stars theory too
the other foreign alliances so the
studies
is too ongoing
to summarize of our
talk today and we think we are in
highly demand for high quality stars
theory dash 2
regions and so this is psychobiological
is working hard on this area
for antibody development no matter
foreign development
antigen with food qualities is a very
key practice
we use several strategies for developing
the stars
where be two research tools especially
for the antibody development
and the first strategy and second
strategy we successfully
get the soft skill to antibodies from
the original
science antibodies or the stars antibody
libraries
those antibodies shows very high
affinity
for binding to the antigen
currently we are still having a lot of
challenges
for obtaining the blood spectrum of
bodies which can recognize
four seven human chronoviruses but we
are working on that
for now we have already
had several fractions of the sars cov-2
research tools including the antigen and
antibodies we have covered
in this part and we also mentioned we
have
several without circuits for detecting
the amount of the antigen
for the antibodies for the
research
this is our last slide we just want to
mention that
other than science will be two
research tools for other chronoviruses
resources
we have a very large fraction of viral
antigens
including antigens to the glandular hiv
rsp and also the antibodies through
all these types of viruses to support
the viral research
and thanks for your time